[Applauso]
partiamo proprio da qua Da cosa nasce
cosa analizziamo Questo questo modo di
dire descrive un passaggio una consegna
un qualcosa che diventa o può diventare
qualcos'altro
giusto qualche esempio un nostro amico
ci mette in
connessione con una passione quella
passione può era la nostra la cosa nasce
cosa Oppure a cena con gli amici a volte
si parla di musica e conosciamo una
nuova musica che non sapevamo esistesse
prima e quella nuova musica diventa la
nostra nuova musica preferita Da cosa
nasce cosa Oppure conosciamo una ragazza
ci
piace scopriamo che ci piace molto di
più la sua migliore amica Ecco Da cosa
nasce
cosa Ma dove possiamo trovare questo
Questo trasferimento del dell'esperienza
se non nel rapporto tra un adulto e un
giovane tra un genitore e un figlio
e se è vero che Da cosa nasce cosa può
anche essere che da una cosa possa
nascere qualche cosa di diverso Cioè non
è detto che quel
trasferimento ci restituisca quello che
ci immaginiamo non è detto che i valori
di
riferimento morali estetici in questo
passaggio si mantengono allo stesso
livello Ok senò non capiremo come da
questo ci sia passati a
questo non ci sapremmo spiegare come da
questo si sia passati a
questo ok Questo forse è un po' estremo
ma quello che voglio dire
è
che stiamo comparando due
mondi quello di ieri dove noi eravamo
figli e i nostri genitori erano giovani
padri e madri e quello di oggi in cui i
genitori siamo noi e guardando questa
comparazione mi viene in mente anche una
domanda anche
scientifica Ma cosa cazzo è successo
cioè come siamo arrivati È qui questo Da
cosa nasce cosa io non lo comprendo e e
se è vero che questo passaggio si
trasferisce soprattutto nell'alveolo del
rapporto genitore figlio E allora
andiamoci più dentro no cerchiamo
cerchiamo di capire dove si è inceppato
tutto per esempio si dice che i genitori
oggi non siano mai stati così distanti
dal mondo adolescenziale dei loro
figli però sono molto
presenti io i miei me li ricordo
proprio così
presenti Cioè anche il
dialogo non c'era C'erano certe parole
che non si usavano non so anche certe
domande scomode i nostri genitori non ce
le facevano Ma certe domande scomode Ma
tipo come
stai
Why Anche perché se la risposta fosse
stata
Eh non sto bene Mamma non sto bene papà
magari parliamo un po'
quel punto dire sì sì sì vai a giocare
in camera tua sarebbe stato molto più
difficile quindi Per non correre il
rischio quella domanda non me la faceva
nessuno e oggi invece i genitori
chiedero come stai al figlio come stai È
sdoganato come si usa dire
adesso
cioè come
dire facciamo un
esempio
Allora i miei genitori non erano
presenti per esempio nella vita
scolastica dei figli oggi i genitori
sono molto presenti nella vita
scolastica dei figli sono molto presenti
anche con gli insegnanti sono molto
presenti nel senso che si presentano al
primo giorno lei il professore Ecco
guardi quello è mio figlio Son che si so
quora se gli dà un br voto se la vede
con me la relazione è questa eh Poi non
parliamo di episodi di violenza che ne
so magari
qualcuno gli ruba la gomma si urla al
caso di
bullismo ai miei tempi invece i miei se
penso alla alla mia carriera scolastica
che vabbè non è stata molto brillante
una volta mi ricordo che sotto il voto
del compito in classe c'era scritto poi
per favore chiama i tuoi che gli devo
parlare subito Cioè questo era il uno
dei migliori voti che ho preso Quindi se
penso alla mia carriera scolastica i
miei genitori non erano presenti come lo
sono quelli di oggi e parlando per
scherzo di bullismo se io prendevo uno
sberlone anche forte e ne ho presi
magari da qualcuno più grande dalle
classi più grandi arrivavo a casa e me
ne lamentavo la cosa più compassionevole
era E tu che cosa gli hai fatto quando
andava bene quando girava storto e te lo
sarai meritato e non smetti a rompere le
scatole Sennò ne becchi un altro mai si
sarebbero andati a lamentare a scuola
Mai avrebbero scritto in chat
Quindi da un certo punto di vista i
genitori di oggi sono molto presenti Ma
si sentono distanti dai figli i nostri
genitori erano molto meno presenti ma in
qualche modo le due generazioni erano
più
vicine il contesto la società i
telefonini la tecnologia non lo sappiamo
però un ottimo modo per per capire il
contesto e la società in cui viviamo è
l'ascolto della musica c'è nessuna forma
d'arte come la musica ci restituisce in
modo diretto eh la realtà della
contemporaneità Cioè è comunque più
semplice capire il testo di una canzone
che guardare un'opera di arte
contemporanea allora facciamo questo
gioco io ho
preso questi qua che sono i pezzi più
ascoltati dell'estate Eh sono è la
musica che ascoltano i nostri figli e
poi ho preso i 20 Vabbè qua ne vediamo
solo pochi ma i 50 pezzi più ascoltati
tra l'80 e il 90 cioè quando eravamo
giovani
noi vediamo cosa succede prendiamo un un
pezzo a caso del Ecco prendiamo vetri
neri vedi al settimo posto di Ava No è
di Anna No è di capoplaza già sta cosa
che per farne uno ce ne vogliono
tre Questa è una cifra stilistica della
produzione discografica adess cioè i
questi cacchio di featuring sono sempre
lì a featuring poi capo plazza Ava
Franco Gianni Mario no non c Vabbè
comunque
[Musica]
proviamo non si capisce un
cazzo però vi voglio bene e adesso metto
i sottotitoli però però il fatto che per
capire i nostri figli dobbiamo avere i
sottotitoli questa Ce la dice lunga no
sul livello no di comprensione tra le
due generazioni ora leggiamo cosa dice
qua Ava Anna Anna Chi cazzo canta non si
ancora capito Vabbè uno dei
[Musica]
tre Vabbè spunta un
Mercedes Bad Boy lei sta con un Bad Boy
e spunto Mercedes Cioè non una Clio un
no e già No perché poi riparleremo di
macchinoni
[Musica]
no
Quindi lei lo aspetta in hotel e già il
grano che parte e aspetta il Bad Boy che
arriva in hotel
quindi io che lo facevo in macchina o
Cioè mi sfug che poi ce l'avessi avuto
la Mercedes ma l'avrei fatto molto
volentieri in macchina io lo facevo
nella Panda immatricolata merci di mio
padre Insomma era ben
[Musica]
peggio spunta un Porsche Ma che
cazzo vetri Porsche coi vetri neri
perché quello coi vetri normali è da
barbone cio noi cabiam
Ovviamente questo Vabbè Porsche merced
Questo è un po' Ma andiamo a prendere il
pezzo di di di Blanco invece un pezzo si
chiama bonton pezzo Ascolta dissimo è di
Blanco ma in realtà ci sono Lazza sfera
e basta Michelangelo e drillionaire
Gianni Franco Mario ci non ci
interessano Ma davvero si chiamano
[Musica]
così
avete
sentito nei primi di 15
secondi si
salutano cioè non si conoscono forse non
lo so Forse come alle feste che si
scriveva il nome per non scambiarsi i
germi sui bicchieri non lo so cioè è una
cosa tra l'altro abbastanza consueta ne
ascolteremo altre Ma pensate non so che
ai nostri tempi che ne so i Ricchi e
Poveri Che Prima di cantare Che
confusione Sarà per Ehi Franco Baffo Ehi
Angelo Ehi Brunetta Cioè ci saremo
straniti No per forza di
c andiamo
[Musica]
avanti Quindi come dire non ci giriamo
tanto in non menano il camper Laia sti
ragazzi Gridiamo C di tutto e poi
scopiamo di botto fin Quindi come dire
anche il discorso del sesso è è diretto
No adesso Passiamo a un altro esempio a
tedo e sfera e basta Gianni Franco anche
questi qua si chiamano così
[Musica]
vediamo
band giro di saluti Vabbè come al
solito
[Musica]
Bentley Porsche Mercedes dove cazzo
vivono qu questo Questo è il mondo reale
Guardate che i nostri ragazzi ascoltano
sta roba qua eh
Cioè è questa la roba io non non lo so
vabbè Questo è più o meno passiamo
invece a voi li avete visti Adesso non
vi sto a rimettere la classifica ma
passiamo a un altro esempio che ne so
Gianni Togni Luna la
ricordato Allora già il nome Gianni
Togni
No cioè lui avrebbe potuto Cioè lui
avrebbe dovuto forse cambiare no JT
Moon sfera piena luna e basta capito
qualcosina No lui si chiede cioè come mi
chiamo Gianni las coraggioso lascia
Gianni Togni Cioè vi di mezzo tra un
impiegato le catasso il direttore del
circo
Gianni
vabbè E guardo il mondo da uno BL mi
annoio un
po' bel salto eh cioè di là t'aspetto in
hotel Non credo per giocare adama cioè e
Gianni si scartavetra i maroni guardando
il mondo da un BL C s'annoia pure perché
allora ci
annoiavo
adesso povero Gianni
vè passo le notti a camminare dentro un
metr
beh
Bentley Porsche coi vetri neri Mercedes
e Gianni non c'ha neanche i soldi per
una cazzo di
panda cammina nel metrò come al liceo
che già aveva già non so 20 30 anni non
lo
so ma
cambierò
cambierò arance da un
balcone Cosa fa getta arance da un
balcone c'è di là si cula alla
grandissima e il massimo del rock and
roll per Gianni e buttare l'umido dalla
finestra Ma ragazzi ma qua c'è qualcosa
che non
va Vabbè
vè
Allora va bene Ho ho preso Sì si può
appla Sì sì va bene
Allora vabbè ho preso che forse
all'estremo posto di questa musica c'ho
anche giocato beh va bene non dico cosa
sia meglio cosa sia peggio Non mi
interessa non non non è non è questo
l'intento non non c'è nessun giudizio Ma
anche se prendiamo un maledetto di
Allora
Vasco Vasco era un maledetto cioè no è
arrivato sbronzo alla prima sul palco
dell'Ariston cazzo l'ariston è il
Vaticano Praticamente per cioè quindi
come dire se prendiamo un
maledetto cantava Voglio una vita
spericolata voglio una vita come Steve
McQueen cioè Vasco viveva molto più
pericolosamente la sua vita reale
rispetto a quello che descriveva nelle
sue canzoni c'è la impressione che oggi
i giovani la sparino alta per
spaventarci e il loro linguaggio ci
stanno dicendo delle cose e allora Vasco
sparava molto basso per Spar eventare il
meno possibile cioè due approcci
totalmente diversi opposti però c'è una
cosa in comune c'è un argomento centrale
che entrambe queste epoche mettono
insieme una questione principale l'amore
ognuno a suo modo Vasco a suo modo
Blanco Ava o come il diavolo si chiama
in altro modo dicendo Ti aspetto in
hotel c'è c'è un'attesa dell'amore Vasco
diceva Quanti anni hai bambina Quanti
Dai stasera c'è un bisogno di consenso
un'incertezza quindi non si parla di
amore generico Ma si parla di bisogno di
amore di bisogno di
riceverlo
l'amore che riceviamo quando siamo
piccoli o nell'età dell'adolescenza
può cambiare il corso della nostra
vita ma questo amore
dov'è e dove lo troviamo esattamente
come lo vogliamo noi chi ce lo deve dare
e come se è troppo ne vorremo di meno se
troppo poco ne vorremo di più e non lo
possiamo dire né chiedere non lo
sappiamo dire perché quello che ci viene
dato è giusto e se quello che ci viene
dato quando siamo piccoli non può essere
messo in discussione se quell'amore è
giusto quelli sbagliati siamo noi
quelli che hanno tutto e non si sentono
mai grati di niente quelli che sono
sbagliati e non sanno fare niente quelli
che comunque sempre sono meno degli
altri di tutti è per questo che lei si
taglia per questo che lui si taglia le
gambe le braccia e anche le spalle
quando non c'è più spazio perché dopo un
po' sul corpo e nel cuore non c'è più
spazio lei è forte è coraggiosa ha
resistito ha provato a resistere fino a
che ho potuto ma alla fine quel
Benedetto sangue lo voleva vedere uscire
dalla sua carne perché il dolore nella
testa e del cuore era insopportabile e
incidere la
carne era un sollievo per poco eh perché
basta poco per ricadere che pooi
ricadere non è nulla di così profondo
come un baratro non è nulla di così
lungo come un tunnel No è vicino
vicinissimo Magari nella stanza a fianco
dove ci sei anche tu e non lo sai ma lì
dentro è buio si è ciechi quando si è
dentro e si è totalmente ciechi quando
ci si riaffaccia fuori abbagliati dalla
luce Forse lei ci sta dicendo questo
loro lui ci stanno dicendo questo ci
stanno
chiedendo di andarli a prendere perché
non sanno dov'è l'uscita ci chiamano
ascoltiamolo chiedere
ascolto vicinanza non presenza vicinanza
amore Da cosa nasce
Cosa andiamo a riprenderci
[Applauso]
Grazie